Welcome back to another episode of
What's Up Prof.
Good day, Walter. Hi Martin. Are you
doing well?
Yes, it's been a little bit hectic and
the topic
well,
is responsible for sleepless nights,
right? Yeah, well,
everything is happening simultaneously
in the world.
So, would it be any different inside the
church? No, I don't think so. So, I
think it's time we talk a little bit
about it. But first first, let's pray
about it. Let's pray.
Our heavenly Father,
there's so much happening simultaneously
in this world.
And we have to have a one voice going
out to give the loud cry. So, we need
your help, please.
Help us in this discussion and bless the
viewers and enlighten our minds. In
Jesus' name, amen. Amen.
Now, Martin,
we have consistently tried
to uh
keep personal issues
within the church, etc.,
out of the discussions as far as is
possible without compromise.
But there comes a time when one must
speak, or else one is seen to condone
what is happening.
And so, um
we will be talking about some issues and
I see you chose you chose
a very
interesting title, Weeping for Tammuz.
Now, we're not going to speak literally
about what happened at that time when
this was written in Old Testament times
when the women were weeping for Tammuz,
but it does imply that all is not well
in the house of Israel.
And time that we addressed some of these
topics.
I also believe strongly
Well, I have no choice but to believe it
because it's a it's a very plain
statement in the spirit of prophecy that
there will be a shaking.
And that the straight testimony will
cause the shaking.
Yes, because God will do the shaking.
God will do the shaking and the
testimony will be part of it.
And the testimony is the spirit of
prophecy. Yes.
So, that seems to play a very pivotal
role in all of this. So, let's just
uh have a look at some of the things
that we want to talk about.
We've received a lot of questions.
And I've received a lot of phone calls.
And some people are incredibly upset.
And one has to explain that these things
must happen. Mhm. It doesn't make the
church as a whole
an an apostate institution. This church
is the apple of the Lord's eye. It will
go through to the kingdom.
And we've stated numerous times in the
past that we do not believe in
hierarchical apostasy. Mhm.
We believe that there is apostasy
at every single level,
but there is also faithfulness at every
single level.
And within this dichotomy,
there is a
well,
a rubbing up against each other like
stones in a river.
And eventually, it will come to a
shaking. And also in this church, the
Seventh-day Adventist Church, the power
or the authority lies in the membership.
Correct. It can only change
the direction or thinking or the
doctrines in a session which is
uh which comprises
delegates from the entire church. We do
not have a papal hierarchy.
We do not have a synodal hierarchy. This
is a totally different ball game. So,
people get confused because they are
used to the general uh way in which
things are done out there and assume
that if some leader here or there says
something which is contrary
to what the
basis and the pillars of Adventism stand
for, that the whole church is now
apostate. No, not in this church.
This church is God's remnant that is
going to go through to the kingdom. And
also, if there's unhappiness
with some of the leadership structures
also,
it lies within the church body to
rectify
it.
So, let's just go into some of the
issues that we've been talking about.
There are a number of questions that
have come in. We're not going to have a
typical question and answer, but we'll
use the questions as a basis for our
discussion.
And the first question that seems to be
popping up everywhere now is with the
number of countries now lifting
restrictions,
are we not returning to normal?
In other words, the question is
were we not jumping the gun and crying
wolf again?
And the answer is we don't believe so.
No.
And that's also the thing now. So, once
again,
you've got the religious aspect we'll be
talking about, and you've got the
secular aspect, this one, this not to
returning to normal.
Yes. But like you've mentioned in the
previous episode, it can't be uncoupled.
And it's a returning to normal without
any normality.
That is the big problem. So, let's have
a look at some of these things.
Uh here for example is an article from
the 13th of February in Business Tech
regarding the law and the structures
surrounding the issues that we are
talking about.
Lockdown restrictions in South Africa to
last until the end of the year, health
minister.
Government plans to keep several
lockdown restrictions in place even
after it has lifted the national state
of disaster, says the health minister,
Joe Phaahla.
So, what was he speaking about?
He said, "We are conscious that this is
a matter we cannot avoid forever.
We must define the conditions under
which we advocate or support
mandatory vaccination.
The matter is not off the table. It's
taking a bit longer to formulate."
That's a very interesting statement,
isn't it?
It shows you that there's something
brewing. Yes, they want to say, "Well,
we're we're rolling back the mandates,
but
it's not off the table because we have
to get some things in place, right?"
Exactly. Let's see what they say
further.
The president, Cyril Ramaphosa, has
announced that South Africa's state of
disaster will be lifted once other
measures to regulate and manage the
COVID-19 response are finalized.
What does that tell you, Martin? There's
legislation that they're busy
implementing that won't need a state of
disaster. So, that they can still
continue exactly as they did before
because there will be legislation that
has taken the place of the state of
disaster. Mhm.
We are now ready to enter a new phase in
our management of the pandemic. It is my
intention to end the national state of
disaster as soon as we have finalized
other measures under the National Health
Act and other legislation to contain the
pandemic. In other words, we're going to
shift our emergency powers to ensconced
powers within the current legislation.
Is there a change or is that no change?
No, because now you're just going to
have it in the law, written into law.
So, you're shifting it from one set of
powers to another set of powers so that
you still exercise the same power.
And you can say, "Look what we've done.
We've lifted this, that, and the other,
but we still have you where we want
you."
Interesting that it's a democracy, but
nobody has voted on this. Yes, there's
no democracy
So, we have exactly the same situations
overseas. So, the Canadian situation is
of course world news at the moment with
the truckers and all of these issues,
but I find this one particularly
fascinating.
So, let us have a look what the Prime
Minister Trudeau had to say on the issue
and what
the situation is.
The federal government
has invoked the Emergencies Act to
supplement provincial and territorial
capacity to address the blockades
and occupations. The Emergencies Act
will be used to strengthen and support
law enforcement agencies at all levels
across the country.
This is about keeping Canadians safe,
protecting people's jobs,
and restoring confidence in our
institutions.
So, let's be clear. This is a defining
moment in the history of Canada, in the
history of the English-speaking West.
The Emergencies Act is martial law.
It has never been invoked in the history
of that country. Now, by law, the
Emergencies Act is allowed only in
emergencies, in  urgent and
critical situations that seriously
endanger the lives, health, or safety of
Canadians.
What's happening now does not qualify.
What's happening in Canada now is not an
emergency. Here's what it looked like
this weekend.
Under martial law, Trudeau now has the
power to force banks to seize their bank
accounts, and insurance companies to
cancel their insurance. That means they
can't actually live in Canada anymore.
They are non-persons. They're enemies of
the state, and they will be crushed.
At least one trucker knows exactly
what's coming. He has seen it before. He
came to Canada from Nicolae Ceaușescu's
Romania.
Why did only people meant to vote?
Why 100 people,
180 or 200 people to decide your life or
my or another?
Let the Canadian
You saw men
when some people they decide your life,
like 300 people they decide your life
when you are 30 million.
Let us vote. Today, Canada's Deputy
Prime Minister, by the way, is a former
American journalist, maybe not
surprisingly, announced that going
forward, Justin Trudeau will regulate
all crowdfunding and cryptocurrency
under the Terrorist Financing Act.
Really? So, Justin Trudeau is now in
charge of all of your finances.
So, Martin, what's the bottom line?
As that Romanian or ex-Romanian said,
here are a number of people in
government, however many they are,
whether they be 180 or 200 or 300, who
who cares?
They will make a decision for the
conscience of an entire country,
and enforce that decision against the
people's will.
Is that called democracy?
No. That's called tyranny, right?
Correct. That's called tyranny.
So, the question arises,
how is it possible
that a small number
can decide for the majority
and enforce their will?
And is this in harmony with
the original plan that God had in mind?
It's definitely not in harmony with
that. Okay. Now, can we take this
argument that is happening throughout
the world, because people are incredibly
upset.
They don't want to be pushed around by
legislation
from a handful of governors and
leaders to force their conscience. They
don't want it.
They want to be able to make their own
decisions regarding what they deemed to
be morally correct in their
circumstances.
Is it only Canada, or is this a
worldwide phenomenon? Hmm?
It's worldwide. It's worldwide. Okay.
Moving on now to other global stories,
New Zealand's anti-vaccine protesters,
who have been showing opposition to
vaccine mandates, continue to
demonstrate outside Parliament as Prime
Minister Jacinda Ardern labeled the
protests as being imported.
Demonstrators continue to occupy the
lawns in front of the Parliament for a
seventh straight day,
ignoring all calls by the police to
leave the area. The demonstrators also
blocked streets around Parliament with
their trucks and vans to disrupt traffic
in the region. Protesters have
repeatedly voiced their opposition
against the government's vaccine
requirements that certain workers get
inoculated against COVID, including
teachers, doctors, the police, as well
as military personnel. During a media
briefing, Prime Minister Ardern said
that these protests will not be
tolerated, and that the patience of
authorities is now running thin.
As I've said previously, I very clearly
have a view on the protest, and the way
that they've conducted the protest,
because it's moved beyond cheering a
view to intimidation and harassment of
the people around central Wellington.
That cannot be tolerated, and please be
advised from police that they're taking
steps to address that, but ultimately,
the management of the protest is for the
police.
The protest began last week when a
convoy of trucks drove to Parliament
from across the country, inspired by
protests in Canada. Initially, there
were some thousand protesters, but that
number quickly multiplied as thousands
others joined the ongoing
demonstrations.
A weekend of protesting amid some of the
most famous landmarks in Paris.
Having descended on the capital from all
across France in cars, trucks, and vans,
they encountered a heavy police
deployment.
Nearly a hundred were arrested, and many
hundreds of fines issued.
Next stop, Lille. Around 300 vehicles
arrived in convoy here en route to
Brussels,
but they're not going to be welcomed
there. Officials have already banned a
demonstration planned in the city on
Monday.
By the program
The program is to go see all the
European institutions little by little,
because this is happening at the
European level. We can see more or less
the same thing in all the countries. So,
there is this will to go forward. We
don't know how far we will go, but we
will go forward, and we will make our
voice heard. There is a ban on convoys
entering Brussels. As you say, it is
completely forbidden. The police will
ensure that this ban is respected. The
situation is evolving from hour to hour.
The motorway police are mobilized and
very attentive to everything that
happens.
The Belgian Prime Minister, Alexander De
Croo, has urged would-be attendees to go
protest in your own country.
But that's a message unlikely to go down
well with the protesters.
Well, Martin, obviously,
people are dissatisfied with mandates.
People are dissatisfied with being
forced into positions that they deem
to be against their conscience.
But it seems as their voices will not be
heard. No, it seems like their voices
are going to be silenced.
Now, Martin, the media has spun a
particular narrative,
and it seems as if the powers that be
are satisfied that that narrative is the
one that will carry the day.
But people are no longer as clueless as
they were in the past, and they can look
at other media as well and receive
information.
And whether the the official narrative
is true or not can be weighed in the
balance,
and either be found true or be found
wanting.
Now, here was a very interesting video.
It was on Facebook. We're not going to
show it, because it's in German,
but the link is at the bottom there.
And what it was about is a discussion of
the findings
in the US military,
because 96% of the US military is
actually vaccinated. And they did a
study
of diseases prevalent in the entire
force plus the reserves
between 2016
and 2020,
and compared it with 2021.
So,
a period of 4 years compared with 1
year, and the only difference between
those years
is a vaccination.
And this is going to go to Senate
committees and is being brought before
governments at the moment.
And it is a fascinating story and a
rather sad story, because diseases
since 2021,
as opposed to the previous periods, have
increased by hundreds of percent, even
thousands of percent.
So, they're looking at issues such as
hypertension,
as
neurological problems.
They're looking at cancer.
They're looking at all the general
plethora of diseases.
And the increase is in the hundreds and
in the thousands percent, which is
unprecedented.
So, the story is
was there protection or was it actually
an endangerment? This is being
investigated
at the highest level. And
once these investigations are done, it
will be very interesting.
But people
on the basis of information such as
this, surely have the right to decide
whether they want to be forced into
something or not, right?
And that is what the riots are all
about.
What's astounding to me is that it
continually says
that
even like Trudeau said
this is for the public safety. Yes.
And I I receive on my on my SMSs regular
notifications
as to what my duty in this respect is in
order to remain safe.
Now, what if I believe that my duty in
order to remain safe is exactly the
opposite? I'm not permitted to make that
choice.
No.
Here's an article
which states that WHO
the World Health Organization is a world
government and that there's a power grab
scheduled for the 1st of May 2022
with relaxations
and that you're actually being framed.
The fact that they are suddenly
distancing themselves from the
restrictions is just a game. And that's
basically what we said in our
introduction, right?
The last week of January 2022,
WHO held an emergency meeting and
deliberations in Geneva on expanding its
powers to take over all member states in
the event of a pandemic
and any other form of threat or
disaster.
WHO wants member states to sign a new
treaty
which expands the 2005 treaty. Once
signed by the ministers of health
the WHO constitution, according to
Article 9, takes precedence over a
country's constitution.
So, 189 countries have signed the 2005
treaty during natural disasters or
pandemic.
So, it seems to be as if this is not
just a local
shift, but an international shift. Makes
you think that
in that first article we read about
South Africa
this delay in them lifting the ban and
waiting to get that other things
implemented
uh maybe they're working along with
other countries and maybe even the
world. And getting everything into
place. Yes. Yes.
Now, we read in the spirit of prophecy
at the same time anarchy is seeking to
sweep away all law, not only divine, but
human. The centralizing of wealth and
power.
That's a very important point.
Centralizing of wealth and power.
The vast combinations for the enriching
of the few at the expense of the many.
Have we seen that in the last few years?
The combinations of the poorer classes
for the defense of their interests and
claims. The spirit of unrest, of riot
and bloodshed.
The worldwide dissemination of the same
teachings that led to the French
Revolution. All attending to involve the
whole world in a struggle
similar to that which convulsed France.
We are not de-escalating.
We are shifting
for even greater escalations.
The world is on a precipice.
And the sooner we realize this, the
better. So, those that want to become
complacent
this is the time
to watch. Mhm. And we've seen, like that
trucker said, how's it possible that a
few people in government can force an
entire nation or it seems the entire
world Yeah. into submission to their
dictates, decrees, and will. And it
doesn't stay there. That's why we
continually say you can't uncouple this
from religious because this is happening
right through the board.
So, once religions start picking up
their cue and following the dictates of
governments
well, then you are trampling on the
consciences of the people.
So, let's just go make sure what the
Bible says about it. It states the same
thing in Matthew and in Mark. So, there
are two witnesses testifying to this.
But Jesus called them unto him and said,
"Ye know that the princes of the
Gentiles exercise dominion over them.
And they that are great exercise
authority upon them.
But it shall not be so amongst you. But
whosoever will be great amongst you, let
him be your minister."
So, the Bible strictly forbids the same
attitude as you're finding in the world
today to be implemented amongst God's
people.
It's a law of the Bible.
In Mark we read there came then his
brethren and his mother standing without
sent unto him calling him. And the
multitude sat about him and they said
unto him, "Behold, thy mother and thy
brethren which seek for thee."
And he answered them and saying, "Who is
my mother and my brother or my
brethren?"
And he looked around about on them which
sat about him and said, "Behold, my
mother and my brethren. For whosoever
shall do the will of God
the same is my brother and my sister and
my mother."
So, here is an attempt to tell him there
is an authority
that you have to listen to.
You better go and see what they want.
Now, he's not being rude here. No. But
he's making a very important theological
point.
That those that do the will of God
they are the ones that belong to his
kingdom.
And that would include his mother
and his
half brothers
in this particular case.
So, this is this is what we need to
understand in the Bible. There's to be
no lording over the Lord's heritage.
So, modern, how are we to make decisions
when it comes to matters of conscience?
When it comes to our own spiritual
relationship with God
and our
sense of obedience that we have to
render to the highest authority in the
universe.
We read in letter 88 of 1896, "God is
the ruler of his people.
And he will teach those who give their
minds to him how to use their brains.
As they employ their executive ability,
they will grow in efficiency.
The Lord's heritage is made up of
vessels large and small.
But each one has his individual work.
The mind of one man
or the minds of two or three men are not
to be depended on as certain to be safe
for all to follow.
Let all look to God, trust in him, and
believe fully in his power. Yoke up with
Christ and not with men.
For men have no power to keep you from
falling."
So, modern, we are not to give up our
conscience to the power of a group of
men that try to dictate conscience to
us.
So, that is contrary to God's will.
So, God's will says they may not lord it
over you.
It is not in the order of God.
And that you have a God-given right
to decide for yourself
what is right in terms of your personal
behavior subject to the law of God.
Yes. Those who keep the law of God are
my brother and my sister, etc. So, it's
not that you are without law or without
rule.
But you are to use your own mind
to see whether you are in harmony with
this or that or the other. Yes. So, when
all these things start happening and
it's contrary to what God says
your conscience should be
then you cannot go along with it even if
it is the land the law of the land. Or
the or the law of a hierarchy in the
church.
So, let's take a look at the issue from
this principle of health reform. Because
this is, as we have seen, a health issue
as well, right?
Yes.
The principle of health reform
have been proclaimed by us as a people
for 30 years. And yet there are amongst
us ministers of the gospel and members
of the church who have no respect for
the light that God has given upon health
reform.
It's always surprising to me that the
very ones who have often no respect are
the ones that are so dictatorial. Mhm.
They eat as they please and work as they
please. God calls for a straight
testimony to be given to those who claim
to believe that we are living in the
last days of Earth's history.
Let's just read the highlighted portion.
Here are men who are standing at the
head of our various institutions of the
educational interests and the
conferences in different localities and
in different states.
All these are to stand as representative
men.
To have a voice in molding and
fashioning the plans that shall be
carried out.
They are to be more than one or two
three men to consider the whole vast
field. The work is great.
And there's no one human mind that can
plan for the work which needs to be
done.
Now, very often when you say
representative men,
that means you don't stand just for your
own ideas, you stand for a greater
group.
So, let's say for example,
a church decides that we believe in six
days, literal days of creation.
And they sent a delegation to represent
that view.
Can that delegate represent his own view
and say, "No, I don't believe this and
this is ridiculous in the days in which
we are living."
No, then he's not a representative.
That's so important because
you as like you said, you're a proxy.
So, you're there in the stead of all
these people that you are representing.
And if you're representing a group,
sometimes you have to then set your
opinion aside
to be in tune with those that you
represent.
For example, an ambassador
for a country.
Is that individual necessarily
absolutely in harmony with everything
his government does?
Not necessarily, right? He might
disapprove of this, that, or the other,
but he's there to represent the
government.
So, he's not there to represent his own
views.
And there must be no lording
over or a superior attitude. We must
have no papacy or coercion.
Then as the children of God are one in
Christ, how does Jesus look upon caste,
upon society distinctions, upon the
division of men from his fellow man
because of color, race, position,
wealth, birth, or attainments?
The secret of unity is found in the
equality of believers in Christ.
The reason for all division, discord,
and difference is found in the
separation from Christ.
Christ is the center to which all should
be attracted. For the nearer we approach
to the center, the closer we shall come
together in feeling,
in sympathy, in love, growing into the
character and image of Jesus. With God,
there is no respect of persons. That's
pretty clear, right?
So, Martin, do we have divisions in the
church at the moment? Yes, there's big
division.
Do we have divisions in the world of
politics?
Yes. So, is it because some people think
that they are more equal than others?
Yes, and I think also what the problem
is, some of
worldly and other leaders
are lording themselves over the rest.
So, here we have a serious issue and
from a religious point of view, the
biblical directive is incredibly clear.
Many plans have been devised that God
has not ordained. The root from which
these plans have sprung is the mind of
finite man. God's watchmen have been
blind.
They should have been wide awake to see
that no man's mind, one man's judgment,
was becoming a power that God could not
and would not endorse.
To invest one man or a few men with so
much power and responsibility is not in
accordance with God's way of working.
So, when you set up structures that
become definitive for the body,
you are transgressing God's directives.
That's true.
Correct? Once you have committee or
anything
that makes decisions
contrary to what the decisions of the
body is and then enforce those, it's not
in accordance with what our God's way
work. Okay. We just have to be sure
about these things because we're in very
troublous times
and we are told that there will be a
shaking.
Any man,
be a minister or layman, who seeks to
compel or control the reason of any
other man becomes an agent of Satan
to do his work and in the sight of the
heavenly universe, he bears the mark of
Cain.
Now, the mark of Cain is a very
interesting mark.
It's the same word basically that you
use for the sign that is to be the
symbol of of God's people. The seal. The
seal, which happens to be the Sabbath,
right?
So, the mark of Cain is the mark of
authority. It's the sign of Anu.
And the sign of Anu we find in the papal
courts where the papal courts claim the
authority of that Cain wielded over the
children of disobedience.
And this is what is happening in the
world. We don't want the mark of Cain.
We cannot tolerate the mark of Cain.
And she's very, very straight here by
saying that if you compel or control the
reason of another person, you are an
agent of Satan.
Very dangerous.
Compelling power is found only under
Satan's government.
The Lord's principles are not of this
order. He would not work in this line.
He would not give the slightest
encouragement for any human being to set
himself up as God over another human
being,
feeling at liberty to cause him physical
or mental suffering. This principle is
wholly of Satan's creation.
Now, these are very hard words,
but perhaps it's time that they be made
public
because we are seeing this more and
more.
Not only in terms of the political
arena, but also within the religious
arena. Yes, and the sad part is this
physical or mental suffering we see on
we see now prevalent. Have you had any
emails and and calls about physical and
mental suffering as a consequence of
coercive tactics? Many. Many.
Now, here's another question.
So, that more or less wraps up where we
are in terms of what we can't expect. It
doesn't seem as if those few at the top
want to back down on their claims of
having coercive powers over
large number of people, right?
No, not at all. So, what they are doing
is not in harmony with God's will, but
in harmony with the will of Satan.
That's what we've read, right?
Yes, and it's getting more vicious at
this stage. And as the resistance
increase, eventually you'll have
anarchy.
And when anarchy comes, which is
basically what some of these elites
want, then you will have more force and
eventually you will have tyranny. You'll
actually go into what happened now in
Canada. You'll go to martial law.
And then you'll have tyranny.
Now, Martin, we've had a number of other
questions.
Because if something is not quite right
at at certain levels,
is it only one particular aspect or is
there something that is permeating
the truth and the body
that is of a more sinister nature? Yes,
and it always works in darkness.
So, you don't see it right away. It
creeps up on you.
And then once you see it, you are a bit
flabbergasted about how it has
infiltrated already.
Now, we have received many calls and
many questions regarding this next issue
that we will discuss. Let us make it
quite clear from the start.
We are not here
to attack the church as a body.
But there are certain issues that need
to be addressed at times.
And as we read, where are the watchmen?
They must have a balanced view as to
what is transpiring and they must know
when to sound the trumpet.
So, there have been numerous questions
about the current quarterly study on the
book of Hebrews.
And the people are asking whether the
study Substance and Shadow,
which I did a few months ago, was a
deliberate counter to this quarterly.
Now, I think I can state quite
categorically that that is not the case.
I had no idea
what the next quarterly was going to be
about. I had no idea that it was going
to be on the book of Hebrews.
But I had a terrible urgency
to do a study on the book of Hebrews.
And it was it was an overwhelming
urgency. I would wake up at night
and go and sit and and look at this
issue and and I have no idea why
it was happening.
There was no plan or any surmising on my
part. I had no idea what was coming.
But I was compelled to do it. And so I
sat down and I worked out a study on the
book of Hebrews,
which we called Substance and Shadow.
And it is a verse-by-verse
exposé
of the Book of Hebrews from an Adventist
perspective.
And then the new study came out and many
many videos went round about
the author and all of these things. Now,
we don't want to go into a serious
debate on these issues.
But people are asking serious questions.
And I remember that when I was doing the
study,
I wanted I remembered a a song that my
wife had written.
And I told her, you know, I think that
would work well because it it fits in
with the theme. Can't you please, you
know, write some intro music for for
this program?
And perhaps you can even sing the whole
song. Now, she'd done it previously, but
she wasn't satisfied with that rendition
and wanted to redo it all.
And as you know, you you cannot force an
issue like that. It takes time.
And I had this urgency, so I created
a lot of turmoil.
And eventually, it was done and it came
out.
Now, what are the issues involved?
Well, people have been phoning.
Have they been speaking to you on the
issue? Yes, they've sent me videos, like
you said, and they've asked questions
on the subject.
And
well, it's important. I think one of the
main things we have to
put our mind on
is we don't want to condemn persons
either. No, we don't want to go into
witch hunts.
No.
But this just
shows you again,
we have to be very vigilant when we
study the word of God and any other
publication. All right. So, when I
received all of these questions and some
people were very very
upset
about it. And some of them wanted to
become very condemning.
That I I said to myself,
I better look at this. And so, I
downloaded all of the lessons and
studied what it said and uh
by and large, the lessons are very good.
But there are a couple of issues that
are a little bit bothersome.
And I don't want to say that
the person who wrote it or anything is
necessarily what some of the media is
saying he is.
But let's just look at some few pointers
and then we can discuss what a broader
problem is than just this.
In the introduction, it says, "As we
noted last week, the early New Testament
Christians read Hebrews as a letter from
the Apostle Paul. Strictly speaking,
however, the writer of the Book of
Hebrews appears to be anonymous.
Speculation has been has given rise to
at least 13 possible authorial
candidates, such as Luke, Barnabas,
Jude, Stephen, Priscilla, Aquila,
Apollos, and even Mary, the mother of
Jesus. At the same time, we would be
remiss if we failed to acknowledge that
Ellen G. White attested to Pauline
authorship of the Book of Hebrews.
Not only Ellen White, the Reformers put
it in the King James version of the
Bible, Paul's letter to the Hebrews.
They all believed it, but uh
you know, this discussion is rife. Well,
he does acknowledge that uh
he will stick to what Ellen White said
for the purpose of the study.
But you know, you throw in the doubt.
Then,
there's a statement in lesson two,
which I found rather interesting.
The priests were appointed on behalf of
human beings to represent them and
mediate their relationship with God and
the things pertaining to him.
The priest was a mediator. This was true
of any system of priesthood, whether
Jewish, Greek, Roman, or any other. The
priest makes it possible for us to
relate to God and everything the priest
does has the purpose of facilitating the
relationship between us and God. The
priest offers sacrifices on behalf of
the human beings. The people cannot
bring these sacrifices to God in person.
The priest knows how we can offer an
acceptable sacrifice so that our gifts
may be acceptable to God, also that they
can provide cleansing and forgiveness.
Priests also taught the law. They were
experts in God's commandments, were in
charge of explaining and implying them.
Finally, the priests also had the
responsibility of blessing in the name
of Yahweh. Through them, God mediated
his good will and beneficent purpose for
the people.
Now, that is true, Martin, for the pagan
world.
When it comes to the Jewish economy,
the priest was a type.
That's it. He was always a type of the
great mediator, who is Jesus Christ.
This is a very Catholic concept that the
priest is the one without you without
which you cannot survive.
So, I found this statement rather
bothersome, but uh
for the rest, I would leave it. Now,
here's an interesting article that just
appeared on the 14th of February, 2022.
So, that's very recent.
Where it stated that a Catholic priest
incorrectly performed thousands of
baptisms by changing a word, making them
invalid.
Uh they don't realize that their child
baptism is invalid in the first place,
but
let's leave it at that.
And it talks about this particular
priest, and he had to resign from his
church, his Catholic church, after it
was determined he used the words, "We
baptize you in the name of the Father
and of the Son of the Holy Spirit
Spirit" instead of the correct phrase,
"I baptize you in the name of the Father
and the Son and the Holy Spirit."
So, that's according to the bishop of
the diocese. Now, what was the problem?
The issue with using we is that it is
not the community that baptizes a
person, rather it is Christ.
And him alone who presides at all the
sacraments. And so, it is Christ Jesus
who baptizes.
That's interesting, right?
Yeah.
So, baptism is a requirement for
salvation,
according to the diocese. So, in other
words, it's a sacrament. Through the
act, Mhm. you receive salvation. So,
now, if it's invalid, you're not saved
anymore.
You're not saved anymore. Now, the
interesting thing is,
the priest says I should say, "I baptize
you." Mhm. But it's not him baptizing,
it's Christ baptizing. Now, you must
understand Catholic theology.
In Catholic theology, when a priest is
ordained, he is ordained as an alter
Christus, another Christ.
So, he becomes Christ. That's why they
believe that in the mass,
they create God,
which is more than creating the world,
as they state in their writings.
So, they literally become the mediator.
Now, that is paganism at the highest
order.
And the lesson study is quite correct in
condemning that as paganism, but by
throwing the Hebrews in there, they are
losing the typology.
And uh It's very dangerous, and if you
look at the spirit of prophecy, she
makes it very clear that
the priest has always been a type.
Always a type.
One person phoned me and was exceedingly
irate about
the first few sentences in the study.
And so, we had a look at it just to see
what it was about. And it says,
"It was at church when he first saw her.
He was running an errand, absorbed in
his thoughts, when the sight hit him.
The painting was a little less than 2 m
high and 3 m wide, but the girl
portrayed in it
exerted a strange, captivating force
over the young man.
Why could he not take his eyes off her?
What was it?
After some reflection, he realized that
it was her eyes. The painting portrayed
only her face, and she was intently
looking at something, but what?
And why was she so absorbed in it? For a
long time afterwards, he couldn't get
the painting out of his head.
Several years later, the painter, Arnold
Chimenez, revealed some of its secrets
to him.
The painting was made to attract viewers
to her eyes, but the real secret was in
her pupils.
If you look closely, you would find out
that they reflected what she was looking
at.
Her eyes were looking on Jesus
on the cross.
Now, this is a generalized story about
someone.
And the idea can crop up that this is
making use of
a method that Paul also used when he
said, "There was a man who was taken up
in vision."
He was actually talking about himself.
So, one wonders whether this is a
reference
of of himself.
That he was perhaps looking at this
picture
and then met this uh artist.
Now, it's very interesting whether that
is so or not is now purely conjecture.
But when you look up this artist, Arnold
Jimenez, you will see that he is a a
artist that uh
has many, many
paintings and has many exhibitions.
And he talks about postmodernism and all
kinds of interesting stuff.
And in his collection, this picture that
he's referring to is a picture of Maria.
So, it's Mariology.
And it's very strange that he doesn't
mention this, but just calls it a girl
when it's actually Mary
that we're introducing here.
Now, Mariology is something that has no
place within a Seventh-day Adventist
setting.
Because we are talking about the high
priest. Also, the image
is the crucifix. Yeah.
And when we're dealing with the study on
the book of Hebrew Hebrews, we are
dealing with the living high priest.
Yeah.
So, it's a very strange introduction to
the story.
Another very interesting thing about it
is the way in which he uses Bible
translations.
Now, we're not going to go through the
lesson at all. As I said, the lesson in
general
is written very well.
And uh we can see that they love quoting
the Alex X, the Septuagint.
And uh some of the ideas
that surround that.
Also, another important point is in the
entire study,
he uses every single translation
that is approved by the Roman Catholic
Church, but not once does he use the
King James version.
Now, that is very strange because if
you're going to do a study on the book
of Hebrews
Mhm. and you want to support an
Adventist view on the book of Hebrews,
you have to use the King James or at
least the received text that is similar.
Or else, you cannot prove
uh the Adventist position.
Now, in some cases, like uh
uh whether Jesus went into the holy or
the most holy, you you cannot prove that
from the modern translations.
And this seems to be a strategy. Let's
use the new translations.
And then, what are you going to do with
the distinctive doctrines? Well, you
leave them out, Martin.
You leave them out.
Now, as far as I'm concerned, when
you're dealing with an Adventist study
and you're dealing with a a study that
is a worldwide study on the book of
Hebrews and it is for Seventh-day
Adventists, can you leave out the
distinctive doctrines? That, in my
opinion, is a sin of omission.
And uh a sin of omission can be equally
as great as a sin of commission.
So, this is highly problematic to me.
Uh now, I know that the issue of Bible
translations is always a very, very
sensitive issue.
But uh
when you only quote these modern
versions and you cannot support the
Adventist doctrine,
then that becomes problematic. So, as
far as the lesson is concerned in
general,
it is well written. There are very many
good points in it.
But it could have been written by any
evangelical. It doesn't necessarily have
to be an Adventist when you study it.
One of the most important
doctrines of the Seventh-day Adventist
Church is the investigative judgment.
And the sanctuary message.
Sanctuary message. And the ministry of
Christ, whether he entered into the holy
or whether he entered into the most
holy.
And this issue of Bible translations is
one
that is constantly causing problems
within our ranks.
And there is a hierarchical position
and then there is a general position.
And never the twain shall meet.
Mhm.
Now, what we said in the first section,
does the hierarchical position have the
right to enforce its view contrary to
conscience on the rest of the body? No,
because that's against what God wants.
That's against what God wants. So, if I
see a study like that,
then uh it it creates concern because it
leaves out the distinctive doctrines.
Now, the study that I did, totally
unbeknown
to the fact that this quarterly is going
to be on the book of Hebrews,
is done with the King James version,
verse by verse.
And the distinctive doctrines can be
clearly seen. I'm not saying that that
study is perfect in any sense. It can
certainly be expanded hundredfold
and many, many things can be added.
But at least it is an Adventist study
and people will be able to see what we
as a body
profess to believe.
Now,
while we're on this topic, I know that
we've mentioned that so many times, but
this is a very, very serious issue.
And it lies at the heart of one of the
biggest problems we have in the church.
And that's it. It always comes back
because this is
for me, this is the root.
The true word of God. What well are you
drinking from? That's it. And why why
are they constantly we we addressed it
in our last one quoting the Septuagint,
which is so nonsensical and
contradictory not only with itself, but
with the spirit of prophecy.
And uh here again, the issue is one of
original pioneer Adventist beliefs.
If the spirit of prophecy is part of our
denomination
and anybody
goes contrary to it,
then they have no right to enforce their
opinion or their law on those that wish
to live in harmony with the spirit of
prophecy.
And if those that believe the spirit of
prophecy go along with their dictates
and their coercion,
then they will be going against their
conscience and sinning against their
conscience and against God. There's not
some portions that I can decide this
I'll adhere to and this is what I'll
believe, but the others I'll just want
to disregard because it doesn't fit in
with my personal
system. So, it looks like an opinion,
but this is really at the heart of the
issue. So, let's just go through a few
quotes just to make sure.
When it comes to Bible translations, we
read in The Great Controversy,
the Waldenses were the first of all the
people of Europe to obtain a translation
of the Holy Scriptures
hundreds of years before the
Reformation.
They possessed the Bible in manuscript
in their native tongue.
They had the truth unadulterated.
And this rendered them the special
object of hatred and persecution. They
declared the Church of Rome to be the
apostate Babylon of the Apocalypse and
at the peril of their lives, they stood
up to resist her corruptions. Martin,
they had the truth unadulterated.
They had the original Vulgate, not the
Vulgate of the Catholic Church, Yeah.
but the original translations into Latin
and they had the received text as their
basis.
And according to the spirit of prophecy,
they had the truth unadulterated.
We read another statement from The Great
Controversy, the church in the
wilderness and not the proud hierarchy
enthroned in the world's great capital
was the true Church of Christ, the
guardian of the treasures of truth which
God had committed to his people to be
given to the world. Martin, what are
those treasures of truth? The original
manuscripts.
The word of God, right?
It's actually so logical. I can't
believe that you want to argue on this
point. But we do. This is a serious
issue.
Now,
there were accusations
that the the lesson study might be the
result of infiltration and Jesuit
infiltration. Let's not go there. Let's
just work on the basis of facts.
And let's not label people with uh a
particular label,
but let us
let us at least be able to say, is what
they are saying in harmony with what we
as a people believe and have received as
a special gift, yes or no? Mhm.
Well, we do run into a problem.
Because when anybody else, like Fauci or
anybody else, studies at the Jesuit
institution, we say that they have
Jesuit training.
So, that puts you in a little bit of a
problem if you decide to go and study
there if you are in a church. Uh yes, it
would be it would be highly problematic
to go and study there unless your your
aim was to evangelize, but uh you would
get not very far at a Jesuit
institution.
The the probability of you being
evangelized is far greater than you
achieving anything that they might do.
So, this is serious issue and it lies at
the basis of many of our problems and
conflicts within the church. So, it's
absolutely clear
that the Spirit of Prophecy tells us
that the Waldensians were the guardians
and that they had the truth
unadulterated.
So, let's read a statement from Early
Writings.
Then I saw that God knew that Satan
would try every art to destroy man.
Therefore, he had caused his word to be
written out and had made his purpose in
regard to the human race so plain that
the weakest need not err.
I saw that God had specially guarded the
Bible.
Yet when copies of it were few, learned
men had in some instances changed the
words thinking that they were making it
more plain when in reality they were
mystifying that which was plain.
By causing it to lean to their
established views which were governed by
tradition.
What she's talking about is people
taking the word of God and adulterating
it according to their views, often pagan
views. And we're talking about people
like Origen, for example.
And later those who followed Origen like
Eusebius and those who followed Eusebius
such as Jerome.
And they were
reading these adulterated manuscripts.
And then she warns that
you will see and this is in 1906.
You will see ere long that there will be
those who will become weary of hearing
repeated the things that they ought to
do
but do not desire to do.
And they will change the wording of the
Bible. We know what the Lord says in
Revelation about those who do that. A
perpetual covenant is a perpetual
covenant.
So, we know that there will be a change.
We know that they have changed the word.
That the Lord had specially guarded his
word. So, there must be two categories.
There must be a guarded category and
there must be a false one.
Now, who were the guardians of the true?
The church of God, the people of God,
the Waldensians. Waldensians. The
Waldensians had the truth unadulterated.
Who had the fake ones? The papacy. The
papacy. It's plainest.
Yes. So, now with if you do it like
that, you can say, "Okay, so
what
does the papacy approve of?"
Then it has to fall in that line. All
right. Then let's take it a step further
again from The Great Controversy.
Doesn't our church
at least publicly endorse The Great
Controversy? Yeah. Okay.
While Luther was opening a closed Bible
to the people of Germany, Tyndale was
impelled by the Spirit of God
to do the same for England. Wiclif's
Bible had been translated from the Latin
text. That's the Latin Vulgate of the
Catholic Church, not to be confused with
the Latin Vulgate of the Waldensians
which was based on the received text.
Wiclif's Bible had been translated from
the Latin text which contained many
errors. It had never been printed and
the cost of manuscript copies was so
great that few but wealthy men or nobles
could procure it. And furthermore, being
strictly proscribed by the church,
it had had a comparatively narrow
circulation.
In 1516,
a year before the appearance of Luther's
thesis, Erasmus had published his Greek
and Latin version of the New Testament.
Now, for the first time the word of God
was printed in the original tongue. In
this work, many of the errors of former
versions were corrected and the sense
was more clearly rendered.
Tyndale was to complete the work of
Wiclif in giving the Bible to his
countrymen.
So, the word of God
was in this manuscript from Erasmus.
And this was the received text. And both
Martin Luther and Tyndale used those
manuscripts. This is what God gave to
the reformers.
It's not rocket science.
Now, Martin.
So, for years the received text
was the basis of Protestantism.
The Geneva Bible was based on the
received text. It had used Waldensian
manuscripts
and the Greek manuscripts that came
later. And then Tyndale had used the
received text. Martin Luther had used
the received text.
They changed the language and the King
James Bible was born. Now, it's not
important about whether King James was a
good man, whether he was a bad man.
The question is who translated that
Bible? It was the reformers,
those that stood for principle, that had
been through turmoil and martyrdom and
bloodshed and war. They were the ones
that translated it. And they were very,
very careful in translating it using the
manuscripts
that had become available including
Waldensian manuscripts.
And it's also important to bring in here
that even though the King James is not
infallible, that there's no errors in
it. The received text is where it comes
from and that is where the basis is.
That is where the basis is. So, whether
there's a word wrong here or a word
wrong there is irrelevant. The point is
that the doctrines come from the
received text. That was the Protestant
Bible.
So, now, where do we get these modern
versions from?
You know,
when the Jehovah's Witness Bible first
made its appearance, there was a huge
outcry because of all the changes that
had been made. People were horrified
at the great changes.
But that was the New World Translation.
But the newer translations like the NIV
and the and the ones subsequent to that
make even more differences and more
changes and nobody bats an eyelid.
So, let's just look at this. The Greek
text that we have used as the basis of
our New World Translation. This is what
the forward said.
Is the widely accepted Westcott and Hort
text by reason of its admitted
excellence.
But we have also taken into
consideration other texts including that
prepared by Dr. Eberhard Nestle and that
compiled by the Spanish Jesuit scholar
Jose Maria Bover and that by the other
Jesuit scholar A. Merk. Martin, does
that make you nervous?
I I'll run already. You'll run already,
right? All right. So, all of these
scholars and the Westcott and Hort text
which was based by the way
on the Sinaiticus and the Vaticanus
which they called an ocean of purity
which had so many errors that even the
Pope had a couple of thousand
corrections made to it.
So, these pathetic manuscripts that do
not have the beginning of Genesis or
Revelation or anything in them
and have such ridiculous
add-ons like the Gospel of Barnabas,
etc.
are the basis
for these new translations.
And this is from the Catholic stable.
So, any Bible
that is in this stable is approved by
the Roman Catholic Church. And any Bible
that is based on the received text alone
is condemned by the Roman Catholic
Church. Why would any Protestant
or why wouldn't Adventist want to even
consider using only these translations
when we are told clearly that the
Waldensians had the truth unadulterated?
The only reason I can think of is not to
be looked at as a fool in the world's
eyes. Okay. So, this is to do with
higher criticism.
Okay. Where we have varied from the
reading of the Westcott and Hort text,
our footnotes show the basis of our
preferred reading. We give some
definiteness to the background of the
renderings of our text by showing in our
footnotes the most ancient manuscripts
and versions on which we call support.
Those being of course the Vaticanus and
the Sinaiticus.
The basis for modern Bible translation
is the Nestle-Aland text which is based
on the same handful of manuscripts
described above. In fact, Nestle makes
it clear in stating explicitly that the
Vatican manuscript is to be preferred
above every other manuscript.
Not the proud hierarchy of Rome
but the Waldensians.
Furthermore, their text by their own
admission is based on ecumenical
consideration and is a dynamic
ever-changing
text as the ecumenical climate dictates.
In 1968, the UBS, the United Bible
Societies, and the Vatican reached
agreement that only this text may be
used as the basis for new translations
in churches and in Bible studies.
And there's the quote. Yeah. So, any
Bible that is based on these manuscripts
gets the approval of Rome. So, why in
our Sabbath school only quote Bibles
that have the approval of Rome and not
those that, according to the spirit of
prophecy, had the truth unadulterated?
And especially when you're dealing with
the book of Hebrews. Especially because
you cannot prove Adventist doctrines.
That brings us to the next point.
Why were you banned in Germany? Was the
question.
I've heard that quite quite a few times
that question. You've You've touched on
it a little bit.
I've given a little bit of a testimony
on it. But, while we're on this issue,
let's address it.
This issue, Martin,
on where the Waldenses come from.
This issue on where the true custodians
come from of the word of God is a very
important issue.
Mhm.
Now, many of our scholars
many of our scholars are traveling on
the road of higher criticism
and refuse to accept that the Bibles
that the reformers produced
are still the most reliable. They've
fallen into the trap of these oldest,
most reliable dug out of garbage bins
are the ones to be relied on. And you
know, this is a battle that has been
coming a long way.
Yes. In the 1930s already, Wilkinson
wrote Our Authorized Version Vindicated.
And he received so much flak from the
theologians and the Biblical Research
Institute within the General Conference
on this issue
that
uh it created a major turmoil.
And they took him to task and wrote
documents against them and ostracized
him and marginalized him.
And then he wrote a book of which I only
have a photocopy, but it's nevertheless
the complete manuscript. It's called
Answers to Objections to Our Authorized
Bible.
It's a beautiful manuscript, as you see.
It's very thorough.
And if you read some of the
introductions in this book,
uh then you can see here in the preface,
back in 1930s,
B.G. Wilkinson published Our Authorized
Bible Vindicated. Some of his college
colleagues took exception to his book
and criticized it publicly.
Since Wilkinson, who was a professor in
one of our colleges, was having his
scholarship questioned, it was mandatory
that he reply.
So, Martin, if
uh you get attacked publicly for what
you are saying, sometimes it becomes
mandatory that you reply. Correct.
This book is his reply to their review
and criticism. It literally downs them
on every argument. And Martin, I studied
this.
And it's amazing how often his critics
referred to the margin of the new
translations.
Yes.
Now, the King James also has marginal
readings, but very few and only state
what is in the text in another way.
But, the marginal readings of the modern
Bibles will give you alternative
readings and create so much confusion
that you do not know what is the word of
God anymore.
And these critics would rely on the
marginal readings to criticize
Wilkinson.
But, I've read that and he sawed them
off at the knees.
There is no way in which their arguments
held water in relation to this very
thorough document. And anybody who wants
to study it should get a hold of Answers
to Objections and read it. And
he was also asked not to publish that
book. Yes. He was asked because his
answer was so devastating
to the great bulk of scholars
that uh it would have caused
too much dissension.
And so, because he was a a kind, gentle
person, he rescinded. But, his students
published it eventually because it
needed to come out. And God wants this
information to come out. Now, I have a
question.
We have institutes within our church
that are supposed to be researchers of
the Bible, like the BRI, the Biblical
Research Institute.
And this body has an important role. It
has to do biblical research.
The problem is
when a body such as that gets set up as
the conscience for the rest of the
denomination, exactly. Then you have a
major problem because this God forbids.
Yes, that then you can almost start an
inquisition.
Then you have an inquisition. Now, once
the church or anybody compels you
to subject your judgment to the judgment
of a body within the church,
then they are transgressing what God has
explicitly
prohibited.
Yeah. So, here is a serious problem.
Now,
here's my problem. The BRI has on many
occasions published articles where they
deny what the spirit of prophecy says
about the Waldenses.
They deny that the Waldenses go as far
back as the spirit of prophecy says,
Correct. although other scholarly
studies absolutely support the spirit of
prophecy. Why is there this attack on
the spirit of prophecy?
Why is it that the Biblical Research
Institute,
our institute that is supposed to be the
one that is set up as the judge of
conscience for the entire denomination
without that authority,
why is it that they say that the spirit
of prophecy, that Ellen White was, for
example, influenced by the margin of the
King James Version to come to the
conclusion that the earth is about 6,000
years old? Why don't they want that?
Because otherwise they're going to look
like fools in the world's eyes.
And why do they prefer constantly
quoting the Septuagint, which stretches
those years beyond the 6,000? Same
reason. Same reason. Now, we as a
denomination, do we believe in the
spirit of prophecy or don't we? Yes,
because the Bible
says in Revelation 12:17 that the last
day church, the remnant church, will
have the spirit of prophecy.
Correct. When they therefore imply
that the spirit of prophecy is not
trustworthy there because she was
influenced by the margin, aren't they
making of none effect the spirit of
prophecy? Yes, they are. When they say
publicly in their writings
that uh she had the same inspiration,
but not the same authority, do they not
deny the veracity and the authority of
the spirit of prophecy? Correct. And
they actually
slap God in the face, telling him, "Oh,
so you've inspired this person like
this, but this one doesn't have the
authority, so you've inspired him
actually it doesn't make sense."
That makes God a fool because he's
inspiring some people with no authority
and inspiring others with authority.
Now, what they further claim is that she
used the Bible homiletically, and you
can use it for homiletics, but you
cannot use her for exegesis. Or imply,
at least, that exegesis is not the way
that we should interpret the spirit of
prophecy.
Now, exegesis is expanding what the
biblical text really says, and
homiletics is what you think about it
and what you preach about.
So, when she says, for example,
that the mark of the beast is Sunday
worship, is that exegesis or is that an
opinion, homiletics? Well, that's
exegesis.
That's exegesis. So, if I want to choose
to believe what the basis of this church
teaches, if I want to believe
that the Bible and the spirit of
prophecy are authoritative, then who am
I to believe? Their publications or the
Bible and the spirit of prophecy? Well,
I mean
If the spirit of prophecy says they will
change the Bible and that the Waldensian
documents were the ones that were the
true manuscripts, and those were the
ones that were used by the reformers,
then why should I not be able to believe
that? Yes.
A question was asked, "Why were you
banned in Germany?"
Well, Martin, the first time I was
banned in Germany is because I gave a
lecture
on the Received Text versus modern Bible
translations.
And it was like a nuclear bomb had
exploded.
Mhm.
That's why I was banned.
So, the question is,
is it right for a church leadership to
ban someone because he believes that God
gave the reformers the correct
manuscript on which to base their
translations of the Bible?
Is that a correct thing to do? I think
Is there a fundamental belief within our
church which says that I must believe
Catholic manuscripts? No. Then why ban
me?
Once again, it comes back to what do you
look like in the world's eyes? Okay.
Now, who did they get to support their
ban?
The BRI.
And the BRI had already opined
in their documentations and their
writings of the past that they did not
agree with the spirit of prophecy on the
issue of the Waldenses that the
Waldenses didn't go as far back as it is
claimed.
Also, there's, of course, other issues
that are of interest. For example, did
Jesus go into the holy or the most holy?
Let's not even go there, which is part
of the current uh
Sabbath school lesson as well.
So, when it comes to their judgment,
they are welcome to their judgment. They
are welcome to their scholarly opinions,
but once you set yourself up and assume
that you have more knowledge than the
spirit of prophecy, then I have the
right to choose whether I want to follow
them or whether I want to follow the
Bible and the spirit of prophecy.
My choice is I would rather follow the
Bible and the spirit of prophecy and
therefore be ostracized. That's it.
So, we went into much correspondence.
And I sent them all the details. They
never respond to your questions.
And eventually, I got so frustrated, I
asked them, "Do you still believe that
the Pope is the Antichrist? And can you
trust the spirit of prophecy?" And they
refused to answer those questions.
Well, then I said, "I refuse to answer
yours, too."
And that is where we had a truce. But,
Martin,
the hatchet is not really buried because
the war continues.
Yeah. And it is a matter of conscience
to me.
And it is a matter of scholarship to
them. And these two are going to clash.
Mhm. And I believe
that at some stage, this is going to
cause at least part of the shaking
within this church.
So, why was I banned? I was first banned
because I believe
that the Reformers received text was the
word of God based on what the spirit of
prophecy says. Mhm.
Well, eventually, I was unbanned
because they realized that they don't
really have a leg to stand on on that
issue.
Because there's no law that says I may
not read a Bible like the original
Luther Bible or the other German Bible
that is based on the received text,
the Schlachter Bible, or that I may not
read the King James Bible.
Why should I not be able to read them?
After all, Christianity had based its
face faith on the King James Bible for
decades. Why should I not discard them?
Yeah. And
go a contrary to ones that Rome approves
of. I I challenge God's people. Go and
read first selected messages
and read the section on Jesus Christ and
the sanctuary and see if you can find
one one mention of a modern translation
in supporting all that is written there.
If you find one, then good for you, but
it'll be very few and far between if at
all.
So,
why was I banned again once I had been
unbanned?
Well, I've already told the story.
But, the plot thickens, Martin. It gets
more interesting.
I was banned because I gave a lecture in
which I stated the biblical position
that the Israel of God today is not the
literal current nation in Israel,
but those who are in Christ are the
spiritual seed. Yeah. And I went a step
further and said
that
in fact, physically, most of them were
not even the literal descendants of the
Judeans, but had come from the Khazars.
Not all of them, but some of them.
And this was considered anti-Semitic.
Mhm.
So, I was accused at government level.
Yeah. That's serious.
That's a very serious accusation because
it carries jail term in Europe.
So, someone within the church
actually laid charge
so that the government would have to
investigate this. And this is a very
serious issue.
And immediately, the church hierarchy
sided with the individuals that made the
loudest noise.
Now, those individuals, up until today,
I have never divulged who they were
because uh
I tried to protect my church because
this church is the apple of the Lord's
eye.
But, if things are wrong at the top,
then God will sort it out. And he's busy
sorting it out. It is. Because we have a
situation now where church leadership is
loading it over the Lord's posterity and
is making rules and regulations contrary
to the will of God, in my opinion. Yes,
and siding with state. And there are
many, many that are on the same page,
and articles have appeared in Fulcrum
Seven, which I fully concur with at this
particular stage. But, this plot
is very, very interesting. For 1 year,
there was this investigation. Yeah.
And the government in Germany is
extremely thorough in its investigation.
And after 1 year, finally, I was
exonerated from all these accusations.
But, as I stated before, the church
didn't have the decency
Let's not say the church. Let us say the
certain groups of leaders within Germany
did not have the decency to apologize
for what they had done and what they had
put my family through.
But, it is interesting how this plot
develops.
When we got charge sheet, we saw, of
course, who the people were that had
laid the charge.
Let us continue.
Here's an interesting article,
Adventist Press Services from November
2021,
which says Adventist elected to
leadership of the Berlin-Brandenburg
Ecumenical Council.
At its meeting in November 22, 2021, the
board of directors of the Ecumenical
Council of Berlin-Brandenburg elected a
new chair,
Monsignor Dr. Hans-Jörg Günther, 52,
from the Archdiocese of Berlin is the
chairman of the ORBB
and the 2021 to 2024
term of office. The council leadership
elected Pastor Dietmar Pechel,
here on the right,
from the Free Church of the Seventh-day
Adventist as his deputy. So, here is the
Catholic bishop who is on that council,
and here is the Adventist
representative. Our president
of the Seventh-day Adventist Church,
Elder Wilson, Wilson has made it quite
clear that no church body or individuals
should be part of the Ecumenical
Council.
And this man is part of that Ecumenical
Council. He's a deputy chair. Correct.
So, according to Elder Wilson, he has no
right to be there. According to me, he
is transgressing the plainest laws of
God.
Let's continue. Here's an article from
the 15th of February, 2022.
An Adventist leader bows before golden
idol during an Ecumenical celebration at
the Maria Regina
Martyrum Catholic Church. Adventist
Pastor Dietmar Pechel
is head of the Convention of Seventh-day
Adventist Churches in Berlin, Germany.
He's also the chairman of the Ecumenical
Working Group of Free Churches in
Berlin-Brandenburg.
And on Saturday,
February the 12th, 2022,
at 11:00 a.m., the Adventist Pastor
Dietmar Pechel visited the Maria Regina
Martyrum
Mary Reigning Queen Catholic Church in
Berlin, Germany,
and met with Roman Catholic Archbishop
Dr. Heiner Koch, and Roman Catholic
Monsignor Dr. Hans-Jörg Günther, both
from the Diocese of Berlin.
Also in attendance were Bishop Dr.
Christian Stäblein
from the Evangelical Church in Germany,
and Bishop Emmanuel Christopoulos from
the Greek Orthodox Church in Germany.
And
there is this idol on the stage. Yes,
they were gathering there for an
Ecumenical prayer for the situation in
Ukraine. Correct.
And here is a video of what transpired
there.
And it is important to note that the
person
second in the row,
moving to the front,
is the Adventist representative.
So, Martin, not only did he bow down to
that little golden idol and that drawing
of a calf or whatever above,
but there he is blessing the people on
the right.
And Martin,
that gentleman is the very one who is on
the charge sheet, who accused me to the
government.
And this is the one that received the
support
by upholding that ban by the German
leadership. After you were exonerated by
the government
After I was exonerated by the
government, and not only that, that very
same German leadership just recently, as
we showed in our previous one,
made it quite plain that they have no
problem with Sunday
as it is celebrates uh the resurrection
and that doesn't come into conflict with
the Sabbath, not realizing that it is
the mark of the beast.
So, Martin, do we have a problem
Definitely. in echelons of leadership in
the church, yes or no?
We definitely do and it's nothing new.
Jeremiah had the same problem, that's
why God showed him some things that
happened inside the veil.
Now, again, are we showing this to
attack the church? No, this is not to
condemn anybody or any
church.
This is
to bring to your attention that we have
to start praying for these people and
for the church, our church. Now, Martin,
at the time
when all of this was happening,
uh this gentleman was closely associated
with uh an organization
which is affiliated
with Adventist Today, for example, which
is another organization that doesn't
take kindly to what we have to say.
And I'm wondering whether this is uh a
mechanism that God is allowing
to bring people to the point where they
have to make a decision?
Well, he's doing it with a worldly um
situation, everything that's happening
in the world. Of course, he's going to
do it with his church as well. So, it's
a parallel thing. It's happening in the
world. It cannot be untwined from each
other. And these people that are in
leadership position, that are involved
in all of these things,
and are deliberately attacking those
within the church, not only myself,
that believe in the Bible and the spirit
of prophecy.
I believe that they have no right to be
in leadership positions. They should be
removed from leadership position because
the people decide, not they decide who
will be in leadership. Exactly. And
anybody
in the church or any
organization within the church that
wants to lord it over God's people and
compel them to go against their
conscience also has no right to be in a
leadership position.
So, some of these bodies,
I believe that they are important, they
should be there, but they should never
be given any power
so that they become the conscience for
the church. This is absolutely wrong. We
have no creed,
we have the Bible and the spirit of
prophecy and that will be determined
what we shall believe. It is time for
God's people to take a stand.
When these people work contrary to the
will of God, then it is our duty to
resist and ignore them.
Yes.
It is our duty, like you say,
because if we just continue to
be silent, we are actually complicit.
By your silence, you will condone it.
So, here are some of the pictures from
the Advent Messenger.
And it's also interesting to me that
while I was in that situation,
uh
this gentleman
was constantly referring on his his
Facebook pages
that he has liaison with Jesuits and
that he attends Jesuit retreats.
What are people like this doing in the
Adventist church?
Well, eventually your fruits will start
showing.
Now, we can see where it is leading. Why
is it that the church leadership is
supporting this but ostracizing those
who believe the Bible and the spirit of
prophecy? And to this day, I'm banned in
Germany. Why?
Does I I don't think you have to answer
that.
I I will not. You won't answer it.
Now, Martin, we're not supposed to bow
down to the golden calf.
And we're not supposed to bow down to
dictates which are contrary to the
conscience.
And uh
as we saw from the very beginning of
this talk, when it comes to the secular
issues,
the evidence
that was released in terms of what is
happening in the United States military,
where the disease rate is astronomically
climbing,
and is data that should be able to
inform us as to what our choice choices
should be or could be.
And the issue of all these other
choices,
and the issue of setting up an image to
the beast, in other words, rather
obeying the dictates of governments
contrary to the will of the people or to
the conscience of the people, even if it
is a minority.
And what is happening in our beloved
church is a very serious issue that
needs to be addressed. Yes. You
mentioned that if you put this into the
biblical story of Daniel,
we've had the
health decision. The next will be the
worship decision.
worship decision. Did we see a uh
a typological manifestation of bowing
down to an idol?
I
I think so. Now, what if that idol
becomes the Sabbath?
Will we then also bow down to it? It is
time for serious reflection. I would
make an appeal
to our church
and say, the pioneers believed in the
Bible and the spirit of prophecy.
They say we have no creed except for the
Bible.
They said no man has the right to lord
it over anyone. They said certain bodies
in the church are not necessarily the
voice of God when they speak contrary to
the will of God. We have to individually
make our choices and stand for what we
believe.
And we're going to be faced not only
with the power of the state,
but the Bible and the spirit of prophecy
tells us
that we will even find resistance from
within our own ranks. And it is truth
that forms the basis on what we stand
for and not opinions of certain
individuals.
Maybe I could just put a reminder that
this year there is again a general
conference in session. Yes. Where
important decisions
reflective of the church as a whole have
to be made again. Yes.
Maybe we must rethink
what's going on in the church.
Yes. Maybe we should rethink and maybe
we should rethink, do we still believe
in the Bible and the spirit of prophecy?
And we should rethink, do we want people
in charge who do not believe in the
spirit of prophecy or marginalize it?
Well, since we are on this bandwagon,
Yes. let us uh discuss the next issue as
well.
This article was brought under under my
attention again this week. Actually,
we've put it behind us because this came
out 2 years ago
on one of the lectures that we've that
you've Well, we put together. Yes, and
at that stage, we decided to ignore it
so as not to cause any turmoil, but I
think we're past that stage now. We have
seen where some of these institutions
stand.
And here is an article from Reflections,
Apocalyptic Fiction in Times of
COVID-19.
And this comes from the head of the
Biblical Research Institute, where he
took it upon himself
to attack
uh what we stand for, particularly me,
of course, that I'm their favorite
target, it seems, or one of their
favorite targets.
And he writes, "On the one hand, we
learn that humanity's struggle with the
microbial world is by no means unique to
COVID-19. Indeed, humans have been under
the sword of microscopic enemies since
the entrance of sin. On the other hand,
like other major crises such as war,
pandemics can spark eschatological
frenzies, and even the
post-enlightenment world, some people
remain vulnerable to apocalyptic
speculations. Rather than an
eschatological trigger of the last
events, COVID-19 may be better perceived
as an indication of the ravaging effects
of sin in the world. Unfortunately,
an adverse side effect of COVID-19 has
been the upsurge of sensationalistic
interpretations of biblical eschatology.
One case in point lies in the ideas
propagated by Walter Veith, a South
African zoologist,
and Seventh-day Adventist author and
speaker who runs the Amazing Discoveries
Media Ministry to press home the
argument that the end of the world is
imminent. Veith builds an eschatological
scenario by correlating current events
with quotes from Ellen G. White and
biblical passages.
With the creativity of a fiction writer,
Veith puts together conspiracy theories
merged with an idiosyncratic
understanding of Adventist eschatology
to convey the message that the end is
near.
I find this
rather offensive language, to say the
least.
I I am an ordained minister in the
Seventh-day Adventist Church. I believe
this is the remnant church. I am
faithful in my faith in the spirit of
prophecy. And these people, as we have
indicated, the BRI, publicly have gone
against the spirit of prophecy on many,
many occasions.
And
my question is, who do you want to
believe? These scholars
that want to set themselves up as the
norm and the standard of morality within
the church,
and want to
have it enforced that everybody bow to
their moral superiority?
Or do we believe the Bible and the
spirit of prophecy? If they go against
the plainest statements in the Bible and
the spirit of prophecy,
and justify it by not using the texts
that were given to the reformers, but
rather believe in the Septuagint and
other
sources of information, and to downgrade
the spirit of prophecy to someone who is
influenced by the margin of the King
James Version,
and doesn't believe the early origin of
the Waldenses, then the people will have
to choose between their scholarship
and the plain statements of the spirit
of prophecy.
So, this is the kind of thing that is
happening within the church, and it is
causing the shaking.
But they will readily support those who
bow down to idols in ecumenical
councils, because that's what they did
when I was banned in Germany.
Rather than support those who believe
the Bible and the spirit of prophecy,
and not just me. You know, any of our
speakers that stand firm for these
principles receive the ire of these
people.
And if that is the case, then people
will have to make a choice. Yes.
He continues with many other stories
which uh
he claims are fictional. Especially the
the 6,000 years. This is what
started this whole Right.
Yes, and he gets it all confused as
well.
And uh never mind, I don't want to take
his article apart.
These people need to do some serious
introspection.
And uh if the church as a body believes
that we should bow down to their
superior understanding of issues when
they blatantly contradict the spirit of
prophecy,
well, then they are underestimating
God's people.
Martin, what would be your choice
when you had to believe something? A
scholar that has been educated at Jesuit
institution, or would you rather believe
the spirit of prophecy? I stand firm. I
believe in what God wrote in
If you study the things and you see, all
right, this is not the right
manuscripts, these are the right ones. I
am not looking for excuses to go with
other ones. All right, so bottom line,
this is not a defense
of personal attacks against me or anyone
individually.
This is a defense of what we believe in
terms of the veracity of the spirit of
prophecy.
So, Martin,
if this is causing a shaking, it is not
our individual conflict, it is our
understanding of the spirit of prophecy,
the straight testimony. That's it. The
attack
of this articles, or all these articles,
and all this is
aimed at maybe you and I.
But the problem is it's actually against
the spirit of prophecy and the Bible.
So, choose thee this day whom you will
serve.
If it is the God on the other side,
well,
then choose that. But if it is the God
of the Bible, then choose that.
And to the law
and the testimony. If they speak not
according to this word, there is no
light in them. And true Adventism
is based on
two pillars, the law
and the testimony.
That is our choice for the times we are
heading for. And no matter what anyone
says, whether it is the pope in Rome or
a leader within this church or a body
that is set up to be the watchman, if
they do not speak according to that
word, there is no light in them. That's
the bottom line. And may God help us as
we approach the shaking. And now, if you
might if you shall, please pray for
them as well.
Heavenly Father,
this has been a terrible war.
We've been involved in it for a long,
long time.
And we've felt it come closer and
closer. And it seems, Lord, as if the
final climax is here.
I pray for our church, Lord. I pray for
the leaders.
I pray for those that are in leadership
position and that have positions of
scholarship within the church,
that you will make them realize that
they are not of greater authority than
the word and the spirit of prophecy.
And that you will teach them to desist
from enforcing the conscience of God's
people, which is contrary to your will.
I pray for a blessing upon your church.
I pray for a revival amongst God's
people.
I pray that we may be fitted and squared
for the outpouring of the latter rain.
Because, Lord, if these events are
taking place and the time is as short as
we believe,
then surely the latter rain must be just
around the corner.
Lord, prepare our hearts to receive it
in Jesus' name. Amen. Amen.